uh are you are you recording yeah
okay i have something offline to talk to
you about that you may have already been
approached about
i have okay yeah are you gonna do it yes
hey austin austin uh i've got something
to talk to you about offline after the
call it's very important
yeah yeah yeah yeah have you already
heard about it because you're important
too right so you felt about it
yeah wow i do know about it
i gotta be careful who's listening so
look at the beards
that i'm mostly walking around like this
right now which i feel like your
allergies yes
which i feel like kind of counts as a
beard no it doesn't oh
[ __ ] if trying or if you wanted to
if you could stand next to someone who's
not yet come out of the closet
don't you have to be dating them not
just standing next to them
oh [ __ ] that's true that that makes it
complicated i just feel like i feel very
impressed on this podcast because i
can't grow a bead
and i feel like we should acknowledge
that the beard has to be like in a faux
relationship i thought it was just
like i thought that could work as a
one-off like a single date like or go to
a party
yeah like a short-term relationship it's
associated with
like an hour long yeah but i just don't
think you could be standing next to them
i think it has to be
implied it has to be yeah implied
romantic context for the standing yeah i
don't know
right okay yeah yeah i'm glad you made
it sound like
yeah yeah i thought you were making it
sound like no you have to actually date
them like you have to commit to the
illusion so much that you're just in a
relationship and i thought
well that doesn't sound good for anybody
involved well no
i don't like look this is for science
you know
this podcast feels exceptionally
straight right now
um super straight i am not straight but
let's go define beard because in my head
it wasn't ever manipulative they didn't
no no i think it was always done for the
benefit of their old definitions of
like appearances yeah i think it was
always done for the main for the
maintenance of the hey siri what is a
beard
seriously it's like i don't know how to
answer that question
what do you what do you want from me
right now how you stupid [ __ ]
uh no it says beard is an american slang
term describing a person who is used
knowingly or unknowingly as a date
romantic partner
um so it can be wow knowingly which i
didn't realize
um i thought it was really knowingly or
too cool
knowingly right especially in like old
yeah i've never heard of you
i've never heard of somebody being an
unwitting beard well it's because the
the uh i feel like that's
most common in like the church
where people are trying to not admit to
being
some kind of homosexual and thus have a
permanent beard
yeah but yeah but that would be like a
collusion like
that's the whole point i thought was the
idea of like somebody who's it's like a
wingman or
you know like they someone who's there
to help you the ultimate wingmen
no i don't think a lot of them know a
lot of it's yeah you don't think a lot
of the wives know
no or husbands no no well first of all
in the church
you wouldn't have like uh why this is
true but it doesn't have to be catholic
i was going to say
you just have a bunch of you know
celibate
you know priests we don't we don't want
to get in the weeds of the catholic
church we really don't
again i'm just watching the road you're
walking around trying i'm like
you saw me perk up like you saw the
sparkle in my eyes we're talking about
shirts
let's do it i actually believe
i have i'm very proud
we have i have two potential candidates
for gaming conversation
really count them i'm impressed let's uh
let's let's vet
those um one is that they're both their
news this week of uh
i'm not prepared but one of them was the
i think it was today
um goes to tsushima
sucker punch studio announcing the
director's cut
of ghosa tsushima's coming and i i
i'm instantly com you know contrived i'm
i'm compelled and intrigued at the same
time
i'm intrigued because i want to know
what that looks like goes to sushima
directly
i've been recording this entire time
which is great um so
there is i'm trying to make the the the
studio house marquee
what's house mock is that housework my
apologies
um sony acquires fraternal studio house
mark
yay
um so i think names right it was like
two companies that came together one of
them had the word house in the name and
one was mark
i believe so that's cool
this is house of ducks um
so you've got this and there was also
announced that it was a little bit
smaller
but funcom um is
uh acquiring the studio outsiders
that is developing an incredible game
uh herman hoss also just tweeted that
dutch studio nix's software will be
joining playlists
so yeah those are the two things that i
was like they're gaming news and i was
like i was curious to see what everybody
thought because first of all
you know mike bithell is you being
resident
representative representative of the
indie space
you know you're the spokesperson for all
[Laughter]
you speak for all right i speak your
word
democratically elected i i'm just i'm
curious
um this has been a trend going for a
while as far as like
as we move forward into like game pass i
think that's a lot of it it's just
studios trying to find ways to be able
to sustain themselves
in a in a a a space where
the triple a and there was a whole
weekend like david jaffe we knew that
whole conversation as far as like the
death of
aaa and you know um all of that going
away i
i don't know it's people said that
single player narrative is going away
too and that's not going anywhere
but i definitely feel like the the as is
often true in economics it's the two
two classes are ultimately going to rule
it's going to be the triple a
and and the i guess triple i are the
independent but there's this middle
ground between
where it's like the single a or the
double a games um
are just not going to i feel like those
haven't existed
for a while uh um like the the
the 10 to 20 million dollar games made
under the umbrella of a sony or
microsoft so they're not really
technically
like a high budget indie they're a low
budget
big studio game those that that
demographic
much like in movies seems to have been
essentially gone
for years well owning the speculation or
the speculative nature of
the quadrant of this conversation i am
curious as to what everybody
thinks this means is it as obvious as
ultimately
there will be no independent developer
outside of
or potentially could be every developer
is owned by
some publisher or does this is this just
kind of like
there's no way the the amount of games
that get published on steam even in a
week
there are so many indie studios even if
it's one person that still counts as an
indie if they don't have a publisher
i don't think that that is even feasible
for that to go away
um because there are still people you
know in their spare time making video
games publishing them
but that's what is the structure though
that that's what i see changing it
though
that's my concern still economically
like what is in it for a mike bithell
or a lucas pope or someone along those
lines what possible upside would there
be to acquisition
by a sony when you can make whatever you
want to make money bags mike
it's not resident capitalism it's not
even this is the right it's just
sustainability
it's just it's like i was talking to the
the guy from outsiders he was like
we feel more comfortable now it's like
we've got somebody who's really
got a big stake in us now but that's a
much bigger studio than the average
indie i would think
from the day we arrive on the planet
blinking step into the sun
there's more to see than ever please
don't do that
yeah don't do that just can't allow that
he's got it i'll try it um it's a circle
life though it is like
it is the it is it's how all of this
goes and i think because we're all kind
of time locked into
our specific generation and era we're
kind of
you know activision started a country
because a bunch of
disgruntled devs once saw their own
thing electronic arts is called
electronic arts again because it started
as an independent thing that grew
up and then what does ea do buys up a
lot of small studios those become big
studios like it is just this kind of
this kind of loop
and if you are starting a video game
company
there are pressures on you to kind of at
some point get acquired because you
probably have investors
or you have kind of you an exit strategy
say you know people who don't want to be
working on games their whole lives you
know and it's
that's something that does come up and
you do see uh companies definitely
built around this assumption that they
will get purchased at some point so
they're trying to build up a reputation
to do that
you also have though the opposite which
is companies that
aren't that fussed about that and have
therefore made different choices you can
definitely look around the indie space
and you can see the companies that are
kind of set up to be purchased and
they're making the kinds of
they're making very specific moves and
it's it's stuff that you can spot so for
example
a brilliant example of this is my genre
so like companies that stick to a genre
and just execute again and again and
again that's an amazing strategy to get
sold
or sorry get bought by someone at some
point or to get high-level
uh you know partnerships and
collaborations
um bloober is a great example of a
company that has just consistently
done the same kind of game the medium
folks
the medium folks and now the konami on a
horror game
take five bets what that's gonna be they
didn't get bought
right that's right they're born
medium was um was not on other platforms
right it was just a microsoft
it was just an xbox game yeah but i
don't remember if they were actually
purchased or not like that's definitely
something if you're like a player and
you're like trying to work out if like
your favorite
indie studio is like going to get bought
look for the
if the studio is kind of consistently
doing something and tracking in a
certain direction
you can you see that companies like mine
where we kind of sporadically do
like [ __ ] it we just announced a vr game
like just we're going to do
5 million things we want to do um that
makes us harder to sell
because it's you you know you don't want
to if you're going into the store you
want to buy the
you don't want to buy a meal uh like a
an ingredient or a meal kit
that like makes random weird stuff every
now and again you want like consistency
you want something that's actually going
to deliver on what the label says
and that's something that makes us less
purchasable and it's you can immediately
see that within your studios versus
to correct myself i just want to make
sure um yeah weber did not get bought by
microsoft
it was that they were trying to this is
what i can
kind of infer from these news articles
uh they're kind of
they're very attracted to investors yeah
i bet blueberry have been approached by
a lot of people for purchase because
they are
that kind of company that like
consistently does a certain thing
consistently hits a quality bar you know
they're also bigger than you
think that that's a you know 100 plus
person studio so they're not like this
15 to 20 person studio
they're they're quite large um which in
that case
you know the stability offered to
maintain the payroll
on a company that size oh my gosh
it's huge like it's not necessarily
let's get bored out
it's let's make sure that all of these
employees can feed their families in a
lot of cases
yeah the reality is that no one very few
people running games companies
are like would not be making much more
money if they're in any other field like
most most companies are run by people
who give a crap especially the smaller
scale because like you know we are just
trying to make the next payroll
and i know like i have a burn rate i
know exactly the number
i have to have coming in every month to
pay everyone who works with me
and that's a number and that's and if
you own a company that's a heavy weight
on your shoulders like that is a sure
a thing you're aware of and a number
you're very very aware of versus
many attempted acquisitions might get
people trying to buy you
no no wonder that only happens if you're
angling for it
we've had so well sorry i say no
actually you know what we we've had some
conversations there have been some
things
i did try for the record myself it would
be like 50 quid i think if i remember
right no
we've we've definitely had like early
conversations but i think
we've been really fortunate in the like
all the kinds of games we want to make
we've been at the kind of scale to make
those games so there's not been a big
push for us to go out there and do that
and i think um yeah i don't think we're
necessarily making a scale of game
that works uh works everywhere but we've
had conversations you have chats you
have
you know i've eaten a lot of very nice
meals and a lot of nice restaurants
and and listened to what people had to
say but yeah we never really progressed
anything beyond that
um maybe one day i know i wouldn't rule
it out for sure like it's definitely
something
i'm open to hmm it's interesting because
i
it doesn't it it like it definitely
represents
some sort of a fork in the road for you
as a company because i would think that
for it to make sense for the entity
acquiring
the company you would probably have to
be of some
some scale you'd probably have to have
grown
for it to represent you know the
the the kind of games that would
generate you know
they need to take it forever they need
to look at you as a company and go
and see how you fit into their structure
like the kinds of games they want to be
making
or you know that kind of thing we've
we've actually
if anything we've invested money in more
places like we've
we've done various things and helped
other other teams in other projects
that's kind of been we've been on the
other side of those conversations a lot
which has been interesting
um but yeah it's it's it makes sense and
it's yeah it does come down to stability
a lot of time
it doesn't those deals when you see the
numbers the numbers can sometimes imply
like that you know people are getting
like
very very wealthy but actually like
there's a lot of complete complexity to
how those numbers work out
um the other one that's always fun is
the uh is the golden handcuffs is like
is looking at like a company getting
acquired and then just literally setting
a reminder for like
exactly two years later when they
announced that all the founders have
left on the
on the two-year mark there you know the
contract locks them in for a certain
amount of time and then they leave so
you can
you can see patterns in this stuff once
you've stopped once you've seen it
happen enough times which is
interesting um but yeah i think it makes
that's why i was curious if it handled
well and if the team the other thing is
with the teams looked after
because you you sometimes with these
deals and there are horror stories i'm
not going to repeat on here but there
are
game devs will know immediately the
kinds of projects we're talking about
here that there
are there are companies that have gotten
bored
because of you know projects they've
worked on or what the company is
and then you know the bosses have got
very well paid and no one below that
level has
you know really seen the benefits and
that sucks that's a shame
but i assume that generally obviously
it's impossible to totally generalize
this but
broadly speaking like if someone were to
pick up
um like like like let's
just imagine a a world where um
the john wick hex was like you know just
this
way outperformed even the most
optimistic
expectations and so it was like okay
quickly do another do another do another
and it put they put the company on a
track
where you know you spent the next
several years making that kind of game
and
it did what you were talking about where
like it would it would put a
target over you to be more ripe for
acquisition
sure if we if we if we imagine that
universe for a moment
wouldn't the acquisition make it more
difficult to say
hey we're in six months of
pre-production before this other thing
really kicks off so in the meantime
let's make a solitaire game
and like the things that you've done
seem like they would kind of be
a sacrifice that would have to come as a
result of the
you have to yeah that would that's
that's the other thing we always get
into conversations with interested
parties about is like the freedom right
because
everyone wants everyone wants every
studio wants to get bought
have you know absolute safety nets and
have absolutely no oversight from
corporate and it's like well that's not
really fair
basically yeah that's that's
unreasonable right like
they have they have expectations so yeah
i think it's that's also something
that's tricky yeah we're very
we're very lucky at the scale we are
that we can kind of try different things
and
and do weird [ __ ] and and kind of
explore stuff that would be less easy
within a big corporation but
not impossible
no please i was just saying we wouldn't
have to do so much weird [ __ ] if we had
you know uh the security of course but
you don't do it because you have to
right that's not the impression i have
um sometimes it's practical like i mean
well i'll put a different way it's not
an emergency situation but like if
a lot of like with our subsurface
circular is a good example of this
like that was that we had a team sitting
around with nothing to do
and if a team sitting around with
nothing to do and you're still paying
them
then you've got you might not have a
problem in that moment but you're very
quickly going to develop one as time
goes on because i see what you're going
to burn your money
so yes all of our games are made because
we creatively just dream of making that
project but at the same time yeah there
is a practical layer to that where
you're kind of working out like
okay no we do need to like do some stuff
solitaire is an interesting case because
that's slightly different
um which i can talk about now because we
we announced ark smith
um yesterday so the team at large was
doing this really interesting vr project
i'd step back from that to kind of do
some other things
and had a similar gap where solitaire
conspiracy was because
i was free for a few months but no one
else was so it was like what's the small
kind of game that i can kind of make on
my own so there's
yes you're right those freedoms are
afforded um when you're a small company
you can be a bit more
agile which is often what makes the big
companies want to talk to you because
you're like you made this for this
um solitaire in particular like we got
lots of conversation started with um
with big companies because they didn't
believe us that we made it in four
months
to the extent i had to like i was like
showing them evidence of that because
to a big company that just seems like
such a ridiculous pace to work
um because they have all of the the
barriers you're talking about
you can you have the freedom to be able
to make that
and to be more experimental but do you
feel you have the same freedom to fail
that you'd you would if you were part of
a i'm a very good barman
that's like on a personal level that's
what i cling to like i could always go
10 bar again like no i don't because of
my team that's the yeah that's the thing
like my team would
i yeah it's at this point i have the
responsibility over a team yeah i guess
you have more room to fail but
but where are those lines with the
studio but
do you feel i i i feel like sony
is a very benevolent publisher
i have no ties to sony i can i can say
that right
um i've just seen getting the look
the blank stare i love it
um look i i'm i'm employed by
you name it i mean and we've established
all
of this it's obviously a little annoying
yeah yeah so
i i can say something you know and it's
it's i run the same risk of
disparagement or anything of of of
losing my
employ as well this is this is just what
i have personally objectively seen is
that sony is a very benevolent
publisher in the sense that they really
do invest in especially their first
party studios to make sure that
hey this didn't necessarily perform the
way that we thought it would but we're
still invested in you
but i would have to think of whether
it's anybody sony activision
microsoft anybody they're going to
ultimately go hey man this just doesn't
make sense for us anymore
so where whereas if you if you
fail on your own yeah they can have
you know economic disadvantages and you
and you can fail but
if you get bought and you get that deal
and you fail to a point that the studio
goes we no longer want you
that to me seems like that could be an
even potentially more devastating
failure is that would you say that's
accurate yeah i mean
we've seen it happen right we've seen or
or worse
and this is the hot the truly
heartbreaking one is when you see a
really great developer get purchased by
a publisher or a platform
and then because they didn't know what
they were buying
or the the the things that developer
made don't kind of fit what that
publisher's goals are they end up
becoming kind of a farm
developer they become like the the fifth
team working on a big franchise project
or right
working on infrastructure on a platform
or something and importing houses or
something
yeah it can it can it can be it can be
really that can be really heartbreaking
because that's like that's a
such a talented group of people that
kind of are now stuck not making
would you say that that's more
heartbreaking because of the squandered
like the opportunity cost for the talent
involved working on
menial i say i say with asterisks and
like it's work that has to be done
that they would be asked to do but if
you have a
true top flight level talent that has
been sort of
moved to the side would you say that
that's more heartbreaking
than if they just shuttered that group
and all those people went and found
other jobs
so what you're asking me is uh jack
black's is it better to
was it to explode or fade away in the
kind of high fidelity since you
is that what it what's the line he says
is it better to know what
there it is thank you um
i appreciate it um yeah no i think it
would seem it would seem that it's
better that they would be like
in a realm of two heartbreaking
scenarios the least one would be that
the company get dissolved and everybody
let go because at least their talent can
go look for a home to actually be
leveraged fully well it's the games
industry so
that's the other aspect is it's such a
competitive industry that i don't know
i'm
because it's you're you're right on an
artistic elevated level
but on a practical people have moved
their family to a new town
and kids enrolled in school and they've
got medical bills and you know what i
mean like
that's the problem in the games industry
is is we're we're artists we're
creatives we're following our dreams
but we still you know we still exist
within
if you use like i don't know why they're
wrong
but yeah of indie studios is
they can in a lot of cases have to work
on a lot of stuff that they don't care
about
um yeah i recently
was helping out an indie studio who
basically because one member
uh had i don't know how to fake to be i
guess i'd be fine
um a family member got cancer
and that's extremely expensive um and
it's not like the studio was
incredibly small but small enough that
financially that became a massive
problem
and then the entire studio was basically
trying to
stay as a company but outsource
individual people to work on
whatever they could with whatever skill
that they had and i think that's kind of
a
reality of working at an indie studio is
that you know it's not always this
let's band together and make whatever we
want from a garage
there are also just the real life stuff
that happens to humans
where you can as an indie team have to
end up working on stuff that absolutely
none of you care about or having to
outsource those people's skills
which can happen the exact same way as
being published published by
purchased by a big publisher and being a
porting house
uh if just one bad thing happens to one
team member and you're all good people
and want to help out and that's
definitely
and that's the problem not an
uncomfortable so that's what's that's
what sucks
we've been yeah touchwood we've we've
been lucky because we've
we've always been very conservative kind
of financially as a company we're very
careful
with with our spend um but also
i yeah our games have without we release
enough games and those games are well
liked enough that we've we've
fortunately never had to kind of go into
that
road but you're absolutely right we're
one big emergency away from that right
like that's the
especially especially in countries like
america where that weather
that can have more of an impact um
do you think that the indie game the
movie because i saw people talking about
this on twitter
helped or hurt the image of what india's
or nothing
i think it got a lot of opinions on
those takes
yeah i think i think i think got more
people to get involved
i definitely was a film it was a bit
late to inspire me i was already kind of
halfway through thomas
when i saw it but it was definitely like
an inspiration behind like oh this is a
real
thing so i think it had that positive
impact i think where it's negative is i
think it massively misrepresents
the the the stories behind those games
that it covers like
and who the people making them were um
not in a negative way to anyone involved
um
i've met many people in that documentary
and there are fine people but
it is it it presents it as a kind of
uh it presents these things as underdog
stories like this person
came up with a cool idea for a game and
now they're making it and boom it sold 2
million units
it's like yeah but that person worked on
ports within bigger games companies for
10 years beforehand or that person had
access to
microsoft funding or that person had you
know i mean like it kind of cuts out
some of those stories to kind of
rocky it up a little bit and i think
that's here's how this
25 year old bought an apartment in
manhattan
with just one simple 2 million donation
from their parents you could do it too
and that's and that's i think we accept
that less nowadays than i think we did
when the indie game the movie came out i
think everyone's a bit more aware of
like
how they're being manipulated by the
media they can see him sure
nobody wants to make that movie and
nobody wants to watch that movie
the one that's realistic yeah
come on no you're special if we're
talking about entertainment
especially back then like a documentary
about the game industry when there was
essentially never one before that
certainly i mean this film premiered at
sundance like
yeah it was far and away the most high
profile success on anything
that wasn't about like kojima or will
wright you know like none of us were
pure like
the the going wisdom at the time and i
remember this i remember
many articles about this was like if
you're gonna
you know if you're if you if you want to
be an indie that gets known you need to
build up a personality and the way you
do that is create a good narrative
around yourself
and like rags to riches and all this and
there were articles on games websites
like promoting this as the way to be an
indie superstar right
and i read all those articles and it
kind of worked for me so i'm not going
to knock them too hard
but like there is a there is a there is
a fiction to this stuff there is a
i still see people mentioning thomas was
alone as like uh this it was this guy's
first game and he's like no i'd worked
in industry for like
six years and learned everything i
trained with some very skilled people
you know it's
it's there's a fiction that can be
uh damaging i think potentially but but
i'm not i'm definitely not blaming that
movie in particular i think it's true of
most subcultures and and artistic
movements
um also people never know about
something
until they know about something like
content
and so i know well the things that are
so logically
they're science you gotta listen to the
show
uh sitcom clip show episodes where they
try to just references
ourselves reuse footage to save
deep drive vlog on us at some point star
wars wasn't george lucas's first movie
that's guys it's true that's hot law not
gnar his second arguably it was his lost
but that's fine
by the way how do you say how do you say
his first
howdy phx1138 or it's
he says fix in the movie fix 1138. he's
not seen the movie i'm a poser oh my god
my voice what's happening to me
oh no this is darling i've just been
possessed it's fine
this
i've been in the games industry for 50
years but i'm only 26.
before i was born i was in the games
industry
it's just allergies i don't know why
it's doing so much to me it's awful
it's not allergies darling it's being in
the games industry for 25 000 years
hey people this year seriously it's the
worst
so bad i feel like i'm falling apart out
here
you are in australia everything's trying
to kill you including the air
i have seen one snake and one spider
want to be [ __ ] fighting and the
snake thing was actually really cute
because it was
like that's like the raw shack test of
being trying
to [ __ ] it yielding it right look at
this
hybrid that snake's even a bit of a root
with that sparta hell welcome to
australia
these people created like a wall to stop
anyone from walking over it to let it
get to the other side of the path it's a
cute little snake
uh anyway austin yes so what i was going
to say
um the
whole like it's their first game but yes
they've actually been working for years
and years
every single success story of everyone
you have
ever heard of that whole truth yeah
true wow except who rami rami ismail
he's the
one yeah like like super crate box was
like his first
ever game i am convinced he's been
working in the games industry since he
was born
i think it happened when he was a
student i think like that would so he
would have only been like but even in
1819
i mean that is an extreme example
obviously
like yeah he's the exception for sure
like david milch his first his first
script won an emmy
you know what i mean like he's gonna
mess you up that's gonna mess you up it
did he was an
addict it was terrible the the example i
was gonna bring up was
when house of cards first came out and
everybody was freaking out about the
music is by a guy named jeff beale who
was being treated like
who's this you know fresh face or
whatever and it was like
you know by the time of how i remember
he's a friend of mine i remember
speaking to his wife
at it at an event once and she said you
know
the last couple because he ended up
winning several emmys from house of
cards but he had won
emmy's prior to that he was already like
a fixture
in so many he had scored the show monk
he had scored
rome for hbo he had scorned card of all
like
he he'd been around and and and uh so i
remember but it was like somehow nobody
really noticed
in the outside world until house of
cards kind of cracked the
broader and suddenly he's being asked to
do concerts of you know house of cards
live and blah blah and i remember i was
talking to his wife
and i said you know it's funny that he's
kind of experiencing this
this renaissance but i said for those of
us like i first discovered his music
when i was in college um because you
know
when you want to learn about the
landscape of composers he was very much
part of that landscape
and she goes yeah he's basically a
20-year overnight success
and that phrase that she said has stuck
with me because almost every i mean john
williams was in his mid 40s when he did
star wars
and everyone forgets that he had decades
of work and holly he even won
two oscars before star wars like but yet
just nobody knew who he was well i mean
austin
the moment they knew who he was you
didn't even know how to compose before
journey
that was your that's true you learned
right that was that was i was
into existence i was wheeled into
existence by my meeting with genova
exactly what happens to all of us yeah
no that's the thing people people never
know
the background and sometimes it's a very
romantic story of a
you know the background hustle of
somebody like like a rocky story you say
somebody's you know just pushing for
years and years and years and years and
then
and then sometimes in my case you know i
i you know we did flow
i was a student so like i i definitely
got very lucky very early
but even by the time i did flow i had
done something like 75 student films
you know so it's like even that even
within the
the narrow bandwidth of like yes i
acknowledge i was very inordinately
lucky because i was still a student
it wasn't like it was the first thing i
had done and i would have dropped the
ball if it had been because i guarantee
you
the first 74 of those student films are
not music i
hope to ever hear again that's the same
narrative complexity to how you
communicate that though right like i
think you do have to keep telling the
audience that i mean you do have to keep
well not not so much the audience but
the people who aspire to be creators to
kind of be honest with them about what
the journey was
i think that's where that film maybe
falls down a little bit
in hindsight but chuck said like troy
said the audience
the audience likes like your goal is
well first off i think it asks the
question of what is the goal of the film
because i remember i talked to a
director buddy of mine who saw that film
and he is not a gamer at all
and he watched it and loved it and i
said what do you what spoke to you about
this
and i hadn't even seen it yet but when
we had this conversation and he goes
it's a great study of neurotic obsession
with your craft and your art
he was like that's what spoke to him
about it he was like here's a bunch of
because he felt he resonated with him as
a director he's like i'm a crazy person
that
has bad habits and and like ignores
meals and stuff because i'm working and
that was a movie about those people
being the same way so there's there's a
an adjacent metaphor or or anecdote that
applies to this
in 2003
um
a single event happened that forever
changed an entire sport
chris moneymaker sat down at the
world series of poker final table
and won and it was the that's not
creative determinism if ever i've heard
it by the way
[Laughter]
he had never sat down at a live game
before
because this is at the time where you
could play poker online and he had
won his seat which is normally like a
it's either 10 000 or
30 000 seat um
[Music]
to to buy into the world series of poker
i can't remember at the time what it was
um but he he won his seat by playing
online he had never sat down
face to face and played with another
person now he had probably played at a
buddy's house or he may have gone to a
casino but he had never the whole thing
that they said he had never sat
in a live game before and he sat across
sammy farha
one of my favorite poker players and he
beat him
and it was in that moment where the
entire slogan for
poker became anyone can win
and what you saw was here's this guy
who represented this whole bastion of
players who were playing
i was playing online poker every night
this was what i did
and all of a sudden these people were
coming in with the sunglasses
because that's what chris moneymaker
wore because everyone was now wearing
sunglasses
and headphones with an ipod listening to
music
and the face of poker changed from being
this gentleman's game
from being the social game to being this
incredibly isolationistic
um just different sport like mad
scientist
to prevent tells is that why people do
that is that just uh
yeah so if you can't see my eyes you
can't see any of the micro
you know uh expressions that would that
would give it away
and i'm not listening to anything that's
happening i'm i'm being very solipsistic
and playing in my own
uh my own space are there what are the
cutoff on rules
there out of curiosity like someone
shows up it just like attempts yeah like
they have like a
full like blanket over their whole body
you know like yeah
this is the beauty of it is it there
there there isn't and there's so many
pictures of people that would literally
uh uh uh daniel negrano was one of
my other favorite uh uh he's a very
emotional player he's a very fun
person to watch play poker and if you go
back and watch like some of the world
series of pokers online they're they're
really really entertaining to watch um
but they changed
and like right before that matt damon
does a movie
uh called rounders with uh edward norton
junior
edward norton jr what what are they
covered ed norton i don't think that is
edward norton jr his son um move with ed
norton and matt damon called rounders
because he's a big
maddie was a huge poker player he does
this movie that came out in 2001
and it really just kind of slipped under
the radar but it's a fantastic move
when was it 98. is it 98
i thought it was way after that
interesting um
still 2001 pretty close john dituro is
in it
it's a it's fascinating and it will
teach you more about poker
but the the what i'm saying is all of a
sudden to the
what indie movie uh or indie game the
movie did was the same thing that this
happened with poker
all of a sudden the it it thrust poker
into the mainstream
um it was now i was even in texas and
now all of a sudden there were there
were businesses popping up including one
of mine
where we would put poker tables in bars
and people were it became
america's pastime was playing poker it
it's supplanted and
uprooted and otherwise usurped i even
got into it at that time i never watched
i never watched world series of poker
anything like that but i
my roommates at the time were all so
into it that we ended up playing
hold them like every few nights for for
like a year
and i so i even i was kind of pulled
into the aftershock of just the
ubiquitous popularity that was going on
at that time
i never tracked any other sport baseball
basketball football didn't have a team i
grew up in dallas of course cowboys were
my team
i knew troy aikman and emmitt smith and
all those guys because that was just it
was
inundated in our culture but i never
really tracked a sport
until poker and boxing and boxing was
was because of some friends of mine but
mma and ufc and all of that i never
really
really got into but boy poker i did but
it's one of the worst things ever is is
when we don't account for pure dumb luck
but again that's the story that
everybody wants to see
is that anybody can win nobody ever
wants to hear about the story where
the little shepherd faced the giant and
got his ass weep you know
they which is 99 of shepherds
yes they're gonna die it's like you
remember that other
that other kid joseph that that tried to
go up against the oh yeah dude that guy
got his ass kicked
it's like yeah david actually beat him
that's why i
that's exactly why i said um
that's exactly why i said the um uh
the intent of the filmmakers is is worth
thinking like they want to tell a
compelling story
uh and it's not necessarily even though
it's a documentary
their goal is not to be documentarians
as like some kind of archival record
they want they will dramatize they will
yeah
or you're some kind of advert for now
you know where
it's not a recruitment video right it's
not like join the indie games
i wish media literacy was at this
standard though because i think a lot of
people
myself included when you're not paying
attention not thinking that way i think
it's very easy to be swept along by a
documentary and believe what you're
seeing is truth
tiger king was an amazing example of
this right like the number of people
who were convinced by the editing of
that show that certain events had
happened in a different way than they
did in reality
because as you say it was entertaining
uh is
the worlds people killed themselves
should be taught in schools like it's
such a big problem like people don't
know what allegedly means you know
like that's the thing that has always
really bothered me i was allegedly
people don't know what allegedly means
so frustrating the amount of things
people read a headline and be like fact
like it specifically says that it's not
yet to perform
quotation marks right yeah they're the
whole thing about someone
being caught in the act of crime
whatever it is
theft whatever until the gavel
has fallen and the conviction has been
declared
allegedly is the word you must use and
that
is that is foundational to society yeah
because a lot of people don't know what
it means but even then you still
technically shouldn't write this thing
happen
you you should write this person was
charged for this crime
charged or convicted of yeah it was like
you can't say o.j simpson
killed nicole brown this is where
found guilty of i think that's the
that's the title of the documentary oh
sorry
go on austin that's what i it's just the
i was just gonna say
briefly that this is where our primal
instincts as
you know as tribalistic animals are
always going to be
combating our attempt at
you know rationality and and and a more
dispassionate
look at react it's amazing that we're
even capable
of scientific inquiry
and and logic and rationality we weren't
built for it it's like an unexpected
you know unintentional side effect of
broad human intelligence but
you know there i don't think we'll ever
outgrow
until we evolve into something entirely
different like a million years from now
i don't think we'll ever outgrow you
know the
the lure of click-baity headlines and
things like that where you have to stop
yourself
and say okay well you know so and so
allegedly they put the allegedly so they
can legally cover their ass but they
know that i'm going to gloss over that
and click it because it looks like oh so
and so just got
you know fire or caught for murder or
blah blah blah whatever
uh like we just can't i don't know that
i blame the writers for the headline
that says allegedly
i don't know that i would necessarily
call that click bait if they're writing
allegedly this happened they're not
they're not doing that to try to draw
you in that's
maybe just a fact maybe i'm cynical but
the way it often gets used is that
allegedly is thrown in there
it it reads to me as if they put a word
like that in there
knowing that people are going to gloss
over it or as you say may not even know
what it means but this way they are
legally covered
because it is often still pretty
inflammatory but
technically true well i would think it's
just the only way to write it like there
are
sometimes people suggest headlines that
are like well this one wouldn't be
clickbaiting like but that one would be
three times as long and wouldn't make
sense so i think if you're saying
allegedly this person killed this person
and sure you could say that's
inflammatory but it's a lot easier than
saying
reports are currently suggesting that
somebody killed that this person was
present yeah it has to be considered
the body of your but isn't that the core
thing we're talking about with
documentary as well though
isn't documentary to use your word
austin isn't
isn't every documentary click bait then
because essentially what documentary's
doing
is it's using the illusion of reality
and truth
to make us care more about narrative
fiction right
like if you look at so something like
indian movie i don't pick on it i do
think it's a i think it's an okay movie
i've not got a problem with it
but it's it is you care about that movie
and you enjoy that movie more and you
enjoy its narrative more
because you know the people in it are
real people if it was
a few episodes of mythic quest you
wouldn't follow it as you wouldn't care
about it as much right
so they are having their cake and eating
it too a little bit documentary makers
where they
they are benefiting from the presumption
of the audience
that what they're watching is true doc
you know we are
yeah we're swept along by and as as
consumers of entertainment
who cares right like ultimately like if
you're just watching something fun on
netflix who cares if it's true or not
like that's fine
but where it becomes an issue i think is
yeah like the tiger king is a great
example of like
no that actually like impacted real
people's lives the fallout of that
documentary and actually negatively
impacted the people who were covered
because they were misrepresented
but then you also have um you know
within the game movie like
it's giving and dishonest view of how
indie games are made and
how likely you are to succeed and what
help you need and what help you don't
need and i think that there is uh there
is a human
cost potentially to that the the one i
always use the example of is like thomas
was alone
i spent three years of my life just
working somebody
has an audio thing happening right now
it might be is it me yeah i think it
might be you sorry go ahead i wasn't
sure if it was like somebody else was
crackling for some reason
it sounded like you were interested in
the headphones we go live
to mike bithell on the screen let me
just build up myself yeah
i'll just get my get myself heated up
again we need to leave all this sense
sorry
no school no totally cool um but yeah
like thomas was alone
three years of my life evenings and
weekends getting that done
and then it came out and then six months
later
it got lucky and it was and it took off
that is a brilliant uplifting story of
heroic hard work
in this particular timeline where it
worked out
but for the million other mikes didn't
get lucky that's a guy
like wasting his life on something
that's a
tragic disturbing story about someone
kind of
throwing their time away and that's
that's the stuff that keeps me awake at
night because i'm lucky that i'm in this
version of events but like i could just
as easily be the other guy
um and there's god knows there's more of
the other guy than there is of the guy
who
who has a hit so it's i relate deeply
yeah
it's a it's a tough one to pass it's a
it's a difficult one because
i also watch documentaries to be
entertained i get it
but there is it influences the way we
think about the world because they're
presented as truth
that's i guess there's a reason go ahead
i keep interrupting you mike i apologize
no no no i didn't
i didn't have much else to say you're
good it's the delay it's this atlantic
thing we've got going on
i'll come over to la i've got my second
vaccination appointment so
yay get to l.a it's live
i know one day when you're like
how could you be both there and there is
the dog
is that uh is that is there new law is
there new law in the show that i missed
out on while i was you know you don't
watch the episodes that you
know do you watch actually that's
actually my question for anyone who's
not going to show
i wouldn't watch this if i wasn't in it
because i want you because i mean
i don't watch it when i have a glowing
endorsement for this podcast
i wouldn't watch it isn't it creepy like
because the first time i was off for an
episode i was just you're just
reasonable
it's like watching cctv camera of your
friends hanging out in a bar i wouldn't
want to like but i will say
all of the comments that like because
obviously i see the comments
what are you doing um there were all
these comments
that were very heated about what you do
with your stuff in a hotel room
having not watched that if i need to get
the headline i'll like skim through
things but
having not watched that i was like what
do i land on this
because i wasn't part of that
conversation austin lives
right you're the suitcase guy austin
when you're when you're traveling you
live out your suitcase right that was
the whole thing for me it depends on the
amount of time
i'm getting give me give me a cut off
i'm generally also just a suitcase
but oh look at that waggy tail um i
would say
like when i was in hotel quarantine i
unpacked some stuff
but i'm not two two weeks you're you're
an insane person if you don't pretty
much yeah i will always take my
toiletries out
but i'm i don't i don't want to put my
stuff in drawers that like other people
have just like had their stuff in them
super frequently i don't know but you'll
find was sleeping in a bed
that somebody else slept in um yeah they
bleached or being on a toilet that
somebody else was in
they bleached that too you assume
yes you assume yeah don't go in with
that black light
it's just like a weird anyway that's
where i stand on it but i did have to
think about it when reading a lot of
those what's the cut off
you said two obviously two weeks
in like in like a matter of five days
three days or whatever
the trip has happened yeah after the
trip is like it's really great someone's
gonna troy go shop at a hotel at some
point
each other yeah we can split a room
we can travel together
and i'll meet you downstairs in about 20
seconds i'm like
i will see you in about 15 minutes
yeah i'll give you the opportunity to
get everything people walk in
i'll never forget travis willingham when
i when we just because we we did this
game in in japan and we were there for
two months make sure you're like
ordering furniture and we go in and it
just
somehow been lived into weeks not far
off
so in in tokyo there are these stores
called i'm assuming there's still photos
of you on the wall from five years
earlier somehow
in the same room but their school in
that room
is like but i've always been here no
there are these stores called don k
and you can buy everything from ramen to
a rolex
it's it's this they're like four floors
it's everything about japan that you
love
and i i i got into this place and i was
like
i dig the whole minimalist thing but
there's just a few creature comforts
that i want to be able to have it's like
i want to be able to maybe
do some yoga in here so i went and i was
like don't have enough dishes i saw i
bought some dishes i bought some glasses
i was like
i'm going to be making drinks i bought
some cocktail glasses and some stuff
i was there for like a couple of days
and i was like hey everybody you guys
want to come over and watch something uh
and in my room
we're going to watch travis had never
seen galaxy quest i was like yeah how
are we going to watch it i was like i
just bought an apple tv
and so it's like what it was like yeah i
bought an apple tv
and so it was like i can't believe this
they walked in they're like i had
candles at a yoga mat
they're like what did you move in i was
like it's an apartment
i want to feel it's there's nothing
the difference is is that like i i've
i've
a lot of this holy gary treatment now
after i let no i think our face
[Laughter]
i i think i think i may have said this
in that episode too
so apologies if i'm repeating myself but
there was a period
in in fall of 2006 right before i i
permanently moved to los angeles where i
was
ostensibly homeless and i didn't have an
address like there was no place that
somebody could spend that could send
mail to
and if i wanted to take a shower i had
to pay for it i had to i had to go get a
hotel room and pay for it
and i always had the ability to fi have
a bed i never slept on the street
i never slept in my car i know several
people that have
i didn't have that but i did have for
about
six months i had for three solid months
but six months really
i had this two itinerant feeling
and so it it left an indelible mark on
me to where wherever i go now it's like
hey man even if i'm here for 24 to 48
hours
i'm going to treat this place with
respect and
it's especially for people that are part
of a housekeeping crew
i want to make sure that i'm not the
worst room that they have to clean that
day
it's a it's a it's a rough job and i
know a lot of people like
like [ __ ] it dude i'll trash a hotel
room like austin
particularly all students no the funny
thing is that you get the wintry room
did you
i relate to i relate very much to that
which is exactly why i
basically barely use the room's
amenities
uh yeah like they they they would be
hard-pressed to know if someone's even
using the room when i
someone's staying here exactly i crisply
make the bed in the morning and
everything like i
i i definitely okay i was with you until
i heard that you make the hotel room bed
i i will straighten it up i i don't
first thing that's a childhood thing i
guess but it just it always
it's the biggest improvement you can
make to your room and if you start off
by making your bed you feel like boom
i've i've done something i'm i'm
already on top of my day as opposed to
being behind it i'll be like i've wasted
that time
i'm just going to get in it again
[Laughter]
yeah but you can see the same thing oh i
can't believe i ate that food i'm just
going to [ __ ] it out later
no no one of them pertains to living
so does the other one mental health is
just as important i mean
you have that effect i challenge you
because you don't do it
try this try this for two weeks
every morning as a person with chronic
illness i'm going to use a bed a lot
more than most people
i don't think there isn't how to make it
up every time i would have to do it like
if i'm unwell i would have to do it a
lot
so maybe in my head it's like a am i
going to do this
on it like there are days where i'm
fainting am i going to do this 10 times
in a day
there's a look i don't think i i will
definitely agree
i'm not i'm an apologist for making your
bed because i used to not be and it did
change the way that i
operate as a person like there was a
there was a fundamental shift i was like
i'm gonna make my bed
and it was just it was a small thing
that i could do
in a time where i didn't feel like i had
a lot of control over things and i was
like this i have control over i may not
be able to fix these big problems but
this
one problem right here this you know
six foot by six foot space i can control
and it really made the world small for
me and it helped i understand
that's not for everybody i think the
principle applies and scales to
anything it's just whatever you can do
with that i really like washing my face
in the morning
that's it i got up and i wash my face
and i brush my teeth and if i don't do
that i feel
off that is a friend of mine cola who
is an incredible dude and he's a fitness
just
it's genetically superior it's not fair
but i've watched him
he he used to not be and he is now like
i want to look like cola cause he's
he just is fit for days do you have any
pictures asking for a friend
yeah actually no i'll i'll i'll send it
to you and you'll be like that's not
fair
that's not fair and he's just a cool
dude and i hope that he listens to this
and hears me shout him out because i
just
he's also by night like this molecular
research scientist and
crime fighter and he's yeah i wouldn't
be saying
he's going to be bruising
i was like how do you do this just like
because he's you know he loves his mom
he's great with his mother
he's great with his brother so i asked
he was like how do you do this because
he's saying beautiful
he wakes up
and it goes to work out and i was like
how do you do that it was like
i can't think i have to get up and go to
the gym
right before i go to work he was like
all i have to do is when my alarm goes
off goes brush your teeth
just go brush your teeth because if i
get up and i brush my teeth
it's now harder for me to go back to bed
i'm already more invested
and i was like dude it's actually really
great
good life advice this guy's not right
it's not get up and go get dressed
and go to the gym and deadlift and then
go to work it's just get up and brush
your teeth because once you've done that
yeah the rest is simple you're going to
take life
one quarter mile at a time don't you i
have daily to-do lists that i feel like
are very helpful and again it's also a
thing that i know
that helps people with chronic illnesses
a lot is
i will put wash my hair on my to-do list
i will put
hell yeah have a shower everything i
count that as a win
yeah i usually do it the night before
for what i'm gonna do the next day and i
have everything planned out some things
with time so i know when any meetings
are or whatever
and i cut them off as i get through them
and the sense of accomplishment that you
get from that
i know that a lot of people would be
like you just micromanaging your own
life but i feel like it's really helpful
to stay on track to stay motivated
and to that point make sure that you
don't put stuff on your list
that you know i like i will not put
stuff on my list that i know that i
can't get to that day
yeah guilty of that i put it i'm going
to
do that i'll get to this at some point
in the week i make lists that are
physically impossible to do in a 24-hour
period of time and then i get mad at
myself for and then you do it
no you're doing it wrong i'll say it's
not good
no i i know unpack your
troy your story of like buying cups and
dishes and all that stuff your hotel
room
the one thing like that you just gave me
a flashback on
um that my dad always used to do is when
he
he you know spot mirrors on cars that
they don't come standard but the little
circular curved ones that let you
see the they seem like they should be
built onto all
side mirrors on cars because they are so
useful
um they they basically almost entirely
eliminate your blind spots to either
side they make it really easy to
parallel park they
like they are just such a no-brainer
and my dad developed a sponsor this week
my dad developed such this like almost
ideological obsession with them that he
would
buy and take them with him and put him
on his rental cars
uh just like leaving this sort of he has
theoretically there's like a small
collection of rental cars throughout the
world
of just mysteriously where did these
things come from that he would just
he basically considered his donation to
all future users of that car
you can't put that on the car you're
welcome yeah exactly yeah exactly
he would always travel with him yeah sir
we need to sell insurance on these cars
so please don't put those on wait but
troy did you leave the
stuff in the hotel room if you buy
glasses
you leave it yeah so that stuff but i
was there for
two months i would argue your trash in
the hotel room the stuff's gonna have to
throw out that throw that out
or there's a gift they're not gonna pay
it forward
don't thank me i've been to japan twice
and literally this morning i i love
summer is is great i'm a robe guy uh if
it if the hotel room has a robe
i just want to break down what you just
said was i've been to japan
it's summer i'm a rope guy all as though
that was one coherent sense this all
tracks
it's gonna come back it's
i don't even think the hotel is still
there uh but
and i do think that if there was there's
a fourth piece of trivia that's
intriguing okay mitsui
i basically we're basically watching sam
barlow's her story
in real time you're absolutely right put
me in your game sam put me in your name
put me in your game please put me in
your game
uh mitsui garden hotel it is still there
they have these
great robes and
i loved it so much i was like can i have
this they're like
okay so i brought the road back home to
me
that was 2009 okay i've had this room
for 10 years and i still
every time you get summer is like i
can't wait and i put it on and it's just
this it reminds me of something
i that's the kind of [ __ ] that i love
pam
though
thinner it's it's still it's still like
cotton but it's just thinner
and it's it's really it was used to go
down to the spa as opposed to like a
thick fluffy
you know yeah it's been addressing here
in the morning but it's still warm this
is the most boring part of this
conversation ever
but i have only yourself to blame let's
dig into this
i love to wear my robe but i i would
definitely leave the
the glasses i left the candles i left
the yoga mat and the
and the weights and the i think you're
littering dude i think they all just
have to throw that out
that was that was about to throw out
trash in the hotel room brought back the
apple tv tv
like this guy what did he do and a yoga
mat
it looks like i got raptured i just like
like a a six-pointed star on a
five-player star
that is the floor that is that is not
normal for me like my
my normal thing is i would look as if i
checked in and then never occupied the
room it's like wow
like what i do i think this is a great
thing and i've had someone comment on
this
i will take all of like the towels that
i use i do i use a lot of towels
i i'm not like a re-user of those that's
probably not a very good thing for the
environment
don't give me that face you wash your
face with one towel
because the dog is like absolutely
destroying her entire body so i keep
muting myself so that this
the audio of this episode doesn't just
have a lot of licking sounds in it
because i feel like that's going to be
sort of uncomfortable
but the just the troy facts that we're
getting here that i didn't expect
such as the wiki page is already twice
as long now i use a lot of towels
and what i will do is
that's what the robe is for and then i
i will i will fold up those like in a
nice little like hobos bag kind of thing
so that and i would put i will put those
into the tub
so they walk in they don't have to like
gather up all these things it's just
literally just grab these
and i i saw them they do this with the
sheets they take them and they bundle up
and they they kind of do a loose tie
and i was like oh i'm going to do that
for them and so then we get there
they're like oh this is great this guy
just didn't leave
all of the time it's like 10 kilos
because of the amount of towels that you
use so nobody could lift pretty heavy
for them to try to pick it up
wet all of them i
do dry off in the shower while the
shower is still going
you're reminding me of an old uh it's
not getting dry
you're
you're giving me a flashback to an old
dilbert comic where he's like so he goes
to a store and they're like
you know that'll be you know seven
dollars and 27 cents and he's like well
you know as a as an engineer i try to
make
life better for people so i'm gonna pay
with nine dollars and forty six cents
and like gives them this far more
difficult math
to to like calculate the change with so
you only have to give you back two
dollars
well except no it was a total fail
they're like it's like
you know your your change in response is
like 1.7
it's like very you know anyway it's like
you're like i'm helping you and i just
picture
you this room is so difficult to deal
with because
and troy's meanwhile like patting
himself on the back the whole time
saying you're welcome
i've got yeah using another towel to do
it using another towel for that as well
and toss that onto the pile every time i
leave i i just i would love for
somebody who knew that i stayed at their
hotel
and listened to this podcast please
leave a youtube comment and be like
yes we hate you there's gonna be ten
people pretending to be
the guy who cleaned your room and those
those comments are gonna not be good
they also work in the hospitality
industry and they will look forward to
my visit
i like these guys free glasses it's
great i gotta get an upgrade
i uh come up in the suite it's it's it's
dawning on me
it's dawning on me that if we ever go
somewhere and
share a room everything about the way i
use the room and about you
makes it seem like there will be no
differentiable
difference between you and that room
alone and me and there with you felix an
oscar
first of all aside zero impact on
impact also and i under use towels in
hotel rooms
same exactly i i will reuse the same
hotel the same
towel the whole the whole time yeah
unless i would unless they were there
wait wait wait wait for how long cut off
that's the thing i've never stress
tested that because i so
rarely am in hotels for more than two or
three days but two or three days
if the towel like gets makeup on it like
if it starts having a bunch of marks on
it is what i would say i will swap the
towel out
but i want my makeup over use the towels
every towel's going on the floor every
day i'm a terrible hero yes
i am only i am only bullying you to
avert attention from my own all folks
electric car i recycle
i taught my three-year-old i use water
bottles
tray baking aluminum ones huh
i feel like it's also like the the
toilet seat uh conversation with austin
um yeah my toilet seat has been what a
golden podcast this has been
quite a while because i have a bidet
that
just kind of comes off occasionally and
i don't
seem to have any way to fix it so i'm
not like full austin in terms of just
like making my guests use a broken
toilet seat and i also have no guests
look we don't do a bit more in the
austin camp overall
i think in in how i'd maintain i i
could i could have worse company uh
welcome welcome to the semi fun just
team
here's what i ask if
welcome to the embassy suites thank you
where's your robes and your towels
the only request that i have is once we
return to a normal world and we're able
to do
this live and we're able to do this
where it requires all of us to travel
i please let me do the travel i will be
i that is i i enjoy it oh you want to be
like
like a flight agent like you're gonna
100 i will be the travel agent for play
watch listen
um interesting what that means is that
we're all going to be ended up committed
we're
going in the comments very expensive
it's not even that we all get
humidifiers for the flight damn
straight you do and somebody else i
would like a troy curated trip actually
i think
i think it is curious
you ask anybody that has traveled with
me i it's the one
there's a lot of things that i don't do
well i cannot do any athletic thing
at all but i can travel like a
son of a [ __ ] you have i know
the and i always it's a it's a very very
simple philosophy
try to go make somebody's day better not
worse that's it
if i no matter who i'm coming into
contact with and typically like
gate agents or flight attendants
are habitually their day is
actively trying to be made worse just by
the sheer nature of their their function
of their jobs
as i say the only reason to talk to them
for 99 of customers is something's wrong
you know something's wrong
to fix it and it's probably your fault
troy ross of a glass
here's something that i used to do um
and i would do this on on only on long
international trips
but heathrow was really good about doing
this too
i would it was hard to do this going
to london but always coming back i would
do this
i would i would get to heathrow and then
right before you started
going to the gates i would go and
there's this little
shop uh there in t5 and
i would go get just a little gift basket
like two gift baskets with like you know
some sausage and crackers and cheese
and some candies or whatever and i would
get on board and they were like you know
can i get you anything you know
we're going to take off soon or whatever
i'll be like i got this for you
and i got because there's typically two
flight attendants for each section and
it's like
this is for you and this is for you and
they're like what is this for it's like
look we're going to spend the next
11 hours together and i know that
the food that i'm going to eat is the
same food you're going to eat you're
probably tired of it
so here's something that's just a little
bit different yeah it wasn't thank you
before that you are extra
because you're you're pretty extra yeah
which like i'm not really surprised by
overall
these are extra moves but that's not a
negative
um that's actually a very sweet thing
that i like like a year later six months
later whatever i get on a flight
and they're on like where's my ball
yeah yeah and someone goes mr baker i'm
like
yes you're like i this was who i was
talking about you gave me a gift basket
and people remember that i'm like
dude if i can do that that's great it it
cost
nothing it was just the gesture you know
it's like 15 bucks or something like
that
but i was like you give me something you
give me some pjs and some food and you
know
i'm gonna give you a little gift basket
we we made gift baskets for everybody in
our section
when we travel with uh traveler for the
first time on a plane it's like
nice and it was it was written from and
this one asshole's the only guy was like
i don't want it i'm like it's a [ __ ]
gift from an 18 month old dude
take the chocolate sure take the
chocolates but it was just like hey
it was so cute pam made these little
gift baskets for everybody and it was
like
here's something the guy's like probably
definitely allergic to chocolate and
choice like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you still i want to watch you
break out in hives he's not gonna
we're walking around like hi this is
travelers his first flight we think he's
gonna be great but just in case
and it was it was you know written as it
was by him he was like i'll try to be
sweet but if not hopefully this will
make the flight sweeter
and it was little hershey kisses and
earplugs
and like it was just like a little gift
bass i was like do you know who did like
it
um was it oh [ __ ] what's his name uh
gavin rossdale
from bush and i didn't get a picture of
it but gavin was like i'm so
he was right behind me and he was like
this is the most incredible thing you
guys have ever
done it was like i think it's great and
we just want to make sure that you guys
everyone's paying a lot of money to be
in these seats and they see a baby come
on board
they're like [ __ ] i've been there that's
true i hope traveler
raised hell non-stop stop the entire
you bought some capital that you didn't
spend that's that's that was inefficient
actually
yeah that was yeah if i if it had been
me
after like 75 of the flight they're
wrong
in the rib cage
traveler walked up to gavin because
they're just like
stumbling down the aisle and gavin was
like do you mind
and we're like no and gavin i picked him
was like i miss my kids so much
and seems like they're great at this age
and so i was like the lead singer of
bush
like my son on a flight is awesome let
me tell you my sister had a baby right
that's why i'm home
yeah and we've been out a couple of
times with said baby and she's very cute
the amount of people who
just come over and interact with the
baby
without ever even speaking to my sister
they don't even need to make eye contact
they just go
baby well there's a sign in sheet online
oh overwhelming
yeah maybe she has something set up that
i'm not aware of but i was like
did people just think that they have all
permission to interact with
this child now with someone even trying
to remove uh the
on the pram like someone even tried to
like take up the little privacy shield
thing
yeah that that that's like my baby
that's a whole other level right there
oh weird
i would never that's weird interact with
anyone's baby by choice but if i were to
i would ask first that's quite the hard
turn
traveler was the second baby that i had
ever held in my entire life i have not
yet
held my sister's baby i will before i go
but i haven't yet totally fine
i i i get that one hundred percent
i'm always convinced that i'll be the
reason the baby died so i mean
it's too much responsibility so
resilient baby so you're not gonna
you're gonna be fine you're gonna be
fine i i the the first baby that i held
was pam goes here hold this baby and i
went
and i held the baby i was like i don't
feel good about this at all the safest
place for me to hold a baby would be in
mike's hotel room knowing there is a sea
of towels
he did ask the question and can indie
game studios
persist and i feel like i gave a
reductive answer of of course but i
wasn't factoring in
that you know i thought all that was the
second question was
the ghost of sushima yeah which you
passed on austin so we did not speak
about that as the host of the show
you're allowed to pass on topics yes i
love it my power extends even wait but
to answer the question
yes i think this can and will continue
to exist
i i but i also think that the word has
gotten muddied same as double a
[Laughter]
even triple a is muddy now what does any
of it mean who knows
find out on next week's episode of play
watch listen thanks for watching
everybody i'm alana pierce that's
troye baker that's austin wintry that's
mike bithell
these two use too many towels austin and
i like the environment
yeah we're we're you know we care okay
whatever these will be i'm a vegetarian
i'm fine
electric car you know see you all next
week